good morning John I'm getting kind of
tired of this pre movie release media
blitz they got all of muggle kind under
this spell I mean don't they know four
months ago I got my tickets on Fandango
how much more money could they make
Let Me In or their legs I shall break
the first part of Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows is coming out tomorrow
night and I'm very excited and of course
it's song Wednesday so it's possible
that those two these things have
something to do with each other
I just been reading books and something
just occurred to me while I was reading
another book then I heard would be the
next big thing I thought what would I
give if that could be true up a
feeling and the way out that when I read
to you well that they are million
galleons I dress up like a go to Oh
buttons I can't do my head with a
lightning bolt that on my wand and fire
pump but no matter how many good things
I'm told everything I need
turns out to be
recon well it's been so many years no
matter how I tried to read Oh young
adult fiction I can come in after I add
like water water everywhere and not a
drop to drink my frustration my agony it
pushed me to the brink I keep tilting
back the glass for the hell it takes the
water it seems no matter what I read I
think this is not Harry Potter this is
not Harry Potter well I was pretty
impressed with Frankie London beckster
come here saving the world with a couple
epic pranks and there's no monopoly a
nonhuman people there's fairies buggers
talking cats a knack knack field and
13:1 loops was fantastic but my speaker
scope would be flat sheet speeding if I
said that it was the best book I've read
and you gotta know that this is no joke
when I also read lots of books that my
brother
[Music]
well it's been so many years no matter
how I tried to read more young adult
fiction I can come in I'll Drive like
water water everywhere and not a drug to
treat my frustration my agony have
pushed me to the brink I keep tilting
back the class for unella test the water
it seems no matter what I read I think
this is not Harry Potter no this is not
Harry Potter in the darkest hours my
darkest nights I found myself curled up
with Twilight and I couldn't help but
wonder as I ravenously reckon you Avada
Kedavra
the not dead cuz Edward Colin totally
has it coming and if guess I'll hold him
off any better start running cuz there's
not much that the Dark Lord and I could
agree on but I think that we would both
hate that guy and Sir Nicholas the
mentee Parkington is a character named
by itself
breaking down
[Applause]
so many years no matter how I tried to
Remo young adult fiction I can call me
and I'm trying
Diagon Alley it's cooler than I'm more
bored in President Snow is no older Lord
and lighter silver tongue is mrs.
Coulter's daughter that's a good plot
twist but in is not Harry Potter no this
is not Harry Potter in addition to being
excited about Harry Potter I was also
really excited about the release of
Assassin's Creed Brotherhood 2.0 isn't
that what it's called and so I've
decided that I'm going to play it and
talk at the same time and then put those
videos up on the internet and yes I did
steal this entire thing completely from
Toby Turner so if you want to watch me
play assassin's creed please come by and
do that hopefully it will be somewhat
entertaining it certainly is for me
youtube.com slash hankgames
John I'll see you on Friday